good morning Hank I know what you're
thinking you're thinking my older
brother really needs a haircut well Hank
I have one thing to say to that
never Hank the reason I haven't gotten a
haircut recently is that I'm trying to
set an all-time personal best puff level
a record currently held by two-year-old
me who looked like a girl now Hank
you're probably saying John your hair
and your head can't even fit in the same
video frame surely you have a higher
puff level now than you did back then in
this picture when your puff level was
probably only three inches but Hank
you're forgetting something important at
the time of my record puff level I
myself was only 33 inches tall that
means that my puff was one eleventh of
my size well obviously Hank since then
my body has grown so if I'm gonna break
the record my puff level has to grow to
111 to 72 inches would be like 11
Hank I think I'm gonna have to call
nerdfighter resident mathematician and
future state representative Daniel Biss
I did a really good job of saying that
uh what's one 11th of 72 be serious
you did it fast all right thanks six
point five four five four five four five
four five four five four five four into
infinity Hank do you want to know why we
need state representatives like Daniel
Biss it's because it took him less than
one second to figure out what one
eleventh of 72 is Hank with those kind
of math skills Daniel Biss is gonna pone
the Illinois state budget every year so
Hank long story short if I'm gonna break
my personal puff level record I still
have two inches to go I'm gonna do my
best but I bet the yetis gonna stop me
from getting there Oh Hank speaking of
Daniel Biss on Super Tuesday Daniel Biss
won his primary election 100% to 0%
admittedly he was unopposed but still
those are good numbers oh and that
reminds me Daniel is also a finalist for
two golden God awards I don't know what
the golden dot award is but I want him
to win it and Hank I'm gonna ask all
nerdfighters to go and vote for Daniel
here or here or possibly here because
he's up against some pretty stiff
competition in fact tank in one of the
categories he's nominated alongside John
McCain John Edwards and Mitt Romney's
five sons all right I got it I got to
take the hair down a notch I have to
tell you the truth ank I'd begun to
think that maybe the world of the in
your pants joke had kind of reached its
natural conclusion we
found the funniest books that you could
pair with in your pants and then I
received an email from nerdfighter
Alyssa Roark while checking in books for
third graders Alyssa made an important
discovery who gets stuck in your pants
Daniel pants who gets stuck in your
pants oh thank you thank you thank you a
a moon the people that dutton who
decided to rip a a Milne off and turn
his books into easy readers the person
who came up with the title poo gets
stuck thank you all hanck lastly I'd
like to address something sad that I
think is on all of our minds right now
it's Valentine's Day now Hank look I
have the Yeti you have the Catherine
things have worked out pretty well for
us but it wasn't always that way and if
you don't believe me you can ask any of
the 54 girls who dumped me before I met
the Yeti now Hank obviously you and I
are living proof that sometimes a nerd
meets another nerd and they fall a nerd
love but the fact of the matter is that
romance doesn't always come easily -
nerdfighters the only time I really
fully enjoyed valentines day was in like
third grade when I had to make a
Valentine for everybody and everybody
had to make a Valentine for me because
you know that was the only day that
everybody in third grade was nice to me
so here's my idea to try to recreate
that third grade Valentine's Day feel
after we all go vote for Daniel Biss we
all head over to the Ning and everybody
makes comments in this video at the Ning
and then we use those comments to go to
each other's profiles to say hi to each
other happy Valentine's Day to make
little comments on each other's profiles
to try to make sure everybody's happy
maybe we can even make some new friends
on the name so that instead of
Valentine's Day being a day full of suck
Valentine's Day will be the day that you
made new friends Hank happy Valens penis
day thanks for being awesome and as the
kitty hath wrote okay thanks bye